et la question de l'augmentation du
salaire des élus fait jaser et selon un
sondage trois Québécois sondages léger
trois Québécois sur 4 sont contre
l'augmentation de 30000 dollars par an
proposé par la caxe sondage a été
commandé par Québec solidaire et le
débat continue de faire rage entre le
gouvernement et les solidaires en
témoignent cet échange en commission
parlementaire jeudi dernier c'est
important d'écouter un court montage de
ce qui s'est passé en commission
parlementaire
je pose une question ministre
est-ce qu'il est intéressant à faire des
audiences
pas intéressé ou pas intéressant à me
répondre est-ce que le ministre à
l'intention de prendre la parole dans le
cadre de cette étude détaillée je vais
intervenir lorsque jugerais pertinent
intervenir manifestement Québec soldat
peut faire une guérilla ça leur
appartient mais je ne jouerai pas dans
ce film-là
c'est plus intéressant que mes questions
c'est correct on commençait à noter le
nombre de questions que je pose au
ministre et à laquelle il ne répond pas
bon on est rendu à quoi 17 18 on
approche tranquillement du 24
alors le gouvernement accuse Québec
soldat par ailleurs d'étirer des débats
afin de retarder l'adoption du projet de
loi 24 le chef Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
c'est également retrouvé sur la défense
aujourd'hui parce que ce ne sont pas
tous les députés solidaires qui sont
laissés refuseraient une hausse de
salaire en fait monsieur Dubois
n'imposerait pas de ligne de partie on
écoute
moi comme meilleur salarié en 10 mai de
mon caucus comme leaders pomme mon
travail de dire de
d'appliquer des lignes de partie sur le
sur les finances personnelles des gens
on n'est pas compte par principe une
augmentation ou une révision des
conditions des députés mais pas dans un
conflit d'intérêt comme ça ce qu'il faut
aussi c'est d'être capable de prendre
des décisions difficiles un moment donné
il faut aussi prendre des décisions qui
sont
importantes pour la société
de Québec solidaire et voulait venir de
le voir dans la commission parlementaire
jeudi dernier bonsoir Monsieur Leduc
alors pourquoi cette obstruction
à l'adoption de ce projet de loi puisque
vous savez déjà qui va être adopté que
un gouvernement le 90 députés de oui
puis il reste plusieurs heures de
travaux parlementaires il y en a ce soir
il y en a demain c'est ce qu'on appelle
les intensives ici dans le jargon ça
veut dire qu'on sèche plus longtemps
depuis longtemps durant la semaine donc
on est seulement 12 députés nous on a
dit depuis le début qu'on allait prendre
tous les moyens pour essayer de
convaincre le gouvernement de reculer
alors moi j'ai déposé des amendements
j'ai eu des arguments avec le ministre
pour lui dire qu'il faisait fausse route
le sondage de ce matin c'est un des
derniers là qui nous était disponible
pour assez dire au gouvernement regarder
depuis le début on vous dit que nous la
population nous parle et nous dit qu'à
l'époque on tente de la façon dont ça
procède là on s'engage très clair le 3
personnes sur 4 vous le mentionnez
tantôt s'oppose à ça alors là
ce que je vous dis c'est que j'utilise
tous les moyens à ma disposition pour
essayer de convaincre le gouvernement de
reculer est-ce que c'est dangereux
parfois d'utiliser les moyens tous les
moyens puisque aujourd'hui comme un
effet boomerang à votre puisque on
aperçoit le ferry Bosco l'obstruction
tentative d'obstruction à savoir que
vous avez fait des propositions qui
aujourd'hui sont interprétés comme étant
de l'incohérence de la part de Québec
solidaire notamment parce que vous avez
fait 4 propositions les quatre ont été
refusés une d'entre elles s’était de
reporter le tout en 2026 avec un comité
indépendant c'est la position de
principe du parti mais quand vous
proposez d'accepter 20 000 dollars
d'augmentation encore 10000 dollars
demandations vous donnez des munitions
au gouvernement et à vos collègues de
l'opposition quant à la au manque de
cohérence oui ben écoutez cette bonne
gare de la part de la coalition kak et
PLK là qui tiennent tellement à cette
hausse là de nous attaquer de
contre-attaquer alors moi je peux pas
nécessairement surpris là qu'ils
utilisent cette pratique là ce que je
sais c'est que les différents aliments
qu'on a déposé visait vraiment
convaincre le gouvernement de reculer
après ça est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on a
changé de position au Québec soldat puis
que tout à coup on voudrait 20 000
dollars bien sûr que non les gens l'ont
compris à la maison depuis le début on
leur aurait coûté à nauséabes je le
répète ce soir on veut le retrait du
projet de loi après ça ça arrive des
fois qu'on achète à moindre rire adoucir
un projet de loi je l'ai fait mille et
une fois sur d'autres projets là
notamment la grosse réforme de la santé
sécurité ou est-ce qu'on avait des
normes la norme satisfait pas j'essaie
de la descendre un peu est-ce que
c'était ce que je souhaitais l'autre
norme bien sûr que non j'aurais voulu
une meilleure note mais bon bref vous
comprenez un peu vous donner des
munitions à vos à vos adversaires et en
slam monsieur nano Dubois a été un peu
beaucoup un peu beaucoup coincé par les
journalistes matin dans ces
contradictions là il a même dit qu'il
était pas au courant de vos propositions
madame Dussault vous savez combien de
projets de loi on gère de front ici là à
l'Assemblée nationale probablement une
5-6 par jour minimalement moi-même je
suis le leader parlementaire qui est en
charge des travaux je ne connais pas la
nature de toutes les amendements que mes
collègues vont déposer dans une journée
ça serait juste physiquement impossible
de connaître tout ça
il faut être correct les principes
défend par le parti moi je pense que
c'est très cohérent ce qu'on a fait dans
la mesure ce qu'on veut faire reculer le
gouvernement on veut à moins dire le
projet de loi on parle ici de d'un total
de 5 millions de dollars qui vont être
payés par les contribuables à l'effet de
d'augmenter les salaires de députés
est-ce qu'on aurait pu réussir à le
réduire un peu on l'a essayé le
gouvernement s'en sort pour essayer de
faire un peu de judo c'est dans l'ordre
des choses moi je me sens pas du tout au
cohérent aujourd'hui ici je sais que je
travaille dans l'intérêt de la
population le sondage le matin de ce
matin le démontre en même temps si votre
crédibilité au cohérence est amoché avec
cette stratégie là comment vous en
remettre par exemple monsieur Nadaud
Dubois dit chacun sera libre je peux me
de
Me gérer dans les finances personnelles
des députés comme vous par exemple si ça
va être voter le 30000 ouais allez vous
prendre le 30000 bah je l'ai déjà
annoncé le dans un point de presse la
semaine dernière que moi non non
j'allais le remettre à des organismes de
mon quartier là un peu comme mon
collègue Gabriel landau du bois moi je
l'ai pas demandé cette hausse là je
trouve qu'elle se fait dans un mauvais
du contexte je trouve qu'elle se fait de
la mauvaise manière en plus avec un
comité pas tout à fait indépendant
certainement pas exécutoire puis que
certainement pas regarder l'ensemble de
la rémunération aucun mot sur le fond de
retraite aucun mot sur les allocations
sur les assurances bref un travail un
peu biaisé alors moi j'ai pas de
problème à leur mettre
l'entièreté de cette somme là mais après
ça si vous me demandez des détails de
quand il commence à se faire je vous
avoue que j'ai concentré mes énergies
sur le fait de combattre cette loi-là
puis assez de la faire reculer est-ce
que j'ai concentré toutes les énergies à
exactement comprendre comment on va le
remettre ça va être compliqué ça va être
malaisant mais vous savez quoi c'est ce
qu'on dit depuis le début que c'est
malaisant cette situation là alors ce
que j'ai un malaise avec cet argent là
puis comment je vais le déplacer je vois
le je dois l'investir ou plutôt je vais
le dépenser dans des organismes de mon
quartier je vais faire des dons oui j'ai
un malaise je ne sais pas exactement
comment ça va se faire mais on va
certainement travailler dans les
prochains jours puis on pourra donner un
plan un peu plus complet là au collègues
des médias dans les prochaines années
parce que c'est un principe c'est
important pour votre partie comment se
fait-il qu'aujourd'hui monsieur n'aurait
du bois dit ben il y a pas de ligne de
je trouve que c'est peut-être un manque
de respect par rapport à ma fonction par
rapport aux gens qui nous écoutent mais
honnêtement ça m'empêchera pas de dormir
ce soir très bien merci Monsieur Leduc
merci à vous au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI